[Music]
hello
how are you
i am wonderful how are you
it is so great to talk to you thanks for
taking the time and congratulations on
the las vegas residency
[Music]
it is so cool i mean you really have
done it all and now you have a residency
to brag about i mean how did this all
come about actually this one was a
cordial invite from the good people at
boombox
um and i'll be appearing alongside the
likes of
trish might know anybody familiar by
nature jj thank you play uh
snap if you guys remember you wrote that
song i got the pop
that was a massive song so um i'm proud
to be in that company you know there
maybe there's a bit of nostalgia there i
mean but
um
the music that people will be hearing is
really timeless so it's got a nostalgic
quality to it but it's not old how are
vegas audiences for you do they differ
from the rest of the country
um i think i think when people come to
vegas i think they come with having a
good time in mind and they may have
something specific that they want to do
but i think everybody's just kind of up
for
um
the uncertain and unconventional and
just like you know just like movies like
hangover like everybody wants to at
least have one hangover experience like
that i mean and of course what happens
if [ __ ] stays in vegas so but i think
it's all in good clean fun um i think
there's a
uh
a plethora of mystic you can get
involved in but you know i've personally
gone out and been a fan of a lot of the
um the shows i'm going to see uh purple
rain i'm going to see uh
la rive i think i'm pronouncing it the
right way q
um
the beatles love show i've seen that
about five six times you know that's a
good one too i love that one so i shout
those out you know so anybody that's
going to be watching this interview uh
if you're going to be in town around
that time definitely come and see us at
our show the boombox at westgate uh uh
las vegas resort and casino you've
accomplished so so much in your career
is there anything
that you want to do that you haven't
done yet
i want to continue
um with just a level of quality i would
like for
the music i do um and the audience that
has the affinity for it to as live as
long as they can you know like um and
and keep up you know um
a consistency you know a quality of life
a quality of entertainment and you know
i would just like to grow old gracefully
doing anything that i love
boom box a vegas residency on shuffle
brings the party to the west gate may 11
through the 15th and may 18 through the
22